the Transformers franchise has been
nothing if not divisive while some fans
have remained resolutely loyal the
majority of critics and plenty of
average movie goers have criticized its
emphasis on noisy cgi style over
storytelling substance still the series
has raked in a combined total of over
four billion dollars proving there's an
audience for this series where there was
anyway in 2018 paramount tabled plans to
make a transformer 7 for the foreseeable
future why would the studio stop the
machine that transformed the toy line
into a multibillion-dollar global
cinematic affair the answers might
surprise you critical disdain and
financial struggles no studio wants to
invest years of development and millions
of dollars into films that critics end
up trashing with negative reviews
well that concern is usually secondary
to box office grosses the reality is
that with transformers paramount was
seeing both dwindle at roughly
proportionate rates maybe the series
downward trending Rotten Tomatoes scores
indicated a larger problem perhaps the
average moviegoer finally saw what the
critics saw in these films and
consequently chose not to see them
anymore
it's hardly unusual for action
blockbusters to earn middling to
negative reviews but the transformers
pattern was clear the movies were
entertaining fewer and fewer people as
they went along following the second
entry series high of 400 and 2.1 million
dollars in receipts 2009's revenge of
the Fallen domestic ticket sales have
dropped with each installment in the
franchise these movies are extremely
expensive and if audiences are snubbing
sequels to such a degree that more than
100 million dollars disappeared between
chapters maybe it's time for Paramount
to reassess its a worldwide trend too as
2017 s the last night
raked in 500 million less
internationally than its predecessor
2014's age of extinction by 2 the bay
very few people are qualified to direct
a 200 million dollar movie it requires
anime
amount of technical skill leadership
coordination and planning that is why
love him or hate him
studios respect Michael Bay and his
particular set of skills Bay's been
making noise about leaving the franchise
for years but paramount has kept making
him offers he couldn't refuse a gigantic
pile of money
but as of 2017 he has officially
departed the franchise without bay the
studio simply doesn't have a go-to guy
that can guarantee the successful
production of a blockbuster on this
scale a convoluted narrative it's
generous to say that the Transformers
franchise has really never made a lick
of sense but at least the first movie's
plot was simple and elegant a boy finds
out his car is actually an alien robot
and that to go on an adventure to
recover a magic cube it was just
outlandish and silly enough to work from
there however Bay and his stable of
writers have churned out an increasingly
convoluted narrative in revenge of the
Fallen Optimus Prime was brought back to
life by an ancient dagger disguised as a
pile of sand then in Dark of the Moon
we learned that the Decepticons had
actually been within range of earth for
decades and were simply hiding and
waiting for the right moment to reveal
themselves
age of extinction went even further back
in time claiming there were prehistoric
dinosaur transformers then the last
night revealed that bumblebee was a
world war two veteran and that Shia
LaBeouf's character was a descendant of
the knights of the round table where
could the writers have possibly gone
from there fortunately it doesn't look
like we'll have to find out Paramount's
brand priorities movie franchises often
strive to expand the overall brand with
success across other mediums but that's
easier said than done
and transformers is proof the property
is maintained strengthen the action
figure market but there's been little
growth in other areas the publishing
license remains stuck at a b-tier comic
book company while the latest tie-in
video games have been met with middling
or worse meanwhile paramount has plenty
of other big movies for well known and
beloved intellectual properties lined up
for 2019 which means a lot of money is
already at stake currently on the slate
are the long awaited Top Gun sequel
another Terminator reboot and a Sonic
the Hedgehog adaptation they're all
high-profile releases based on huge
brands and they're each risky in its own
way given all the money on the line with
these films it's only logical that
paramount wouldn't want to further
strain its resources on a 7th
Transformers the bumblebee gambit
paramount might also be unwilling to
proceed with transformers 7 until the
results are in for the bumblebee prequel
technically transformers 6 if it turns
out to be the franchise's last hope it's
in good hands
the director is the supremely talented
Travis Knight who delivered the
magnificent Kubo and the two strings if
it bombs that's one more reason why the
studio would be right to wait and get
its transformers house in order before
syncing any more money into it should it
flop that'll probably be the end of the
line for the franchise as we know it
reboot time franchise reboots have
become fairly common lately and to
complete transformers do-over would
achieve a lot of things at once it would
wipe out the absolutely bonkers
backstory that's built up to this point
it could earn a fresh start with fans
provided paramount shows proof that
they've learned from past mistakes and
there's even a chance critics might
learn to like the series so long as
there's enough heart brains and good
old-fashioned fun all it takes is one
press of the reset button and
transformers can reimburse as the
franchise it was always supposed to be
when every blockbuster fan on the planet
can get into
[Music]